hey guys this episode is brought to you
by blue apron blue apron is the number
one fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country
you understand it's guaranteed blue
aprons freshness guarantee promises that
every ingredient in your delivery
arrives ready to cook or they'll make it
right check out this week's menu and get
your first three meals free with free
shipping by going to blue apron dot-com
/ Congrats
you don't do it you bad person hippie
calle [ __ ] it's congratulations
the podcast and it is episode 19 and
we've never done the 19th episode ever
so you baby sit back relax and just
enjoy this I want you to relax I want
you to enjoy this like you got your
hands behind your back
like you're Bruce Willis at the end of
die hard when he's got the gun back
there and he's about to pull it out on
Alan Rickman and then he's and then he
says yippee ki-yay [ __ ]
I want you to put that I want you to
just put your arms back like you're
getting sucked off and you in your
cubicle and just enjoy it
not like that and I want you to know
that this is how we do it man cult cult
city we're building we're building cults
I'm not starting I'm not doing this just
for the podcast I'm building a cult so
government if you're listening come get
me uh let's see what went on with me
this week first of all I want to thank
everybody for listening really we've got
a steady stream of listeners so far now
not going to lie
one more but uh tell your friends
but thanks for
or uh for listening uh and I really like
you guys
for doing that now some of you it is
very weird to think about that some of
you guys who like my podcasts quite
literally have murdered somebody
and that's super odd to think about
because I like that you listen to the
podcast but also you piece of [ __ ] right
some of you guys literally beat the [ __ ]
out of dogs now I like that you listen
to the podcast but you piece of [ __ ]
don't do that listen to my podcasts but
don't beat the [ __ ] of the dogs right
some of you guys have literally there's
a we have enough lizard listeners that I
would imagine somebody definitely who
likes my podcast has [ __ ] on another
person's car now don't do but thanks for
listening okay um yeah so watch yourself
out there is what I'm trying to say and
even though you're nice loyal fan and
you are technically baby you're a baby
if you listen to this podcast and thanks
for that but don't [ __ ] on people's cars
and don't beat the [ __ ] of the dogs
that's my PSA um so uh yeah it don't be
bad purse uh-hmm and for those of you
that don't like the podcast uh lick my
whole [ __ ] as jay-z would say I like
I like to I'm not going to call you guys
haters you know I think I there's this
notion going on has been going on for
years and years about haters and about
how people think that they I don't
here's I don't like that I don't like
when people call people haters because
here's the deal it enables people who
are shitty at things to then keep doing
them and just think because that
somebody's saying that they suck that
they're now they're just haters and it's
like well then [ __ ] them I got to keep
going
because success brings haters yeah
success does bring haters but you know
you also know what brings haters when
you suck at what you do okay if you pick
up a guitar and you start singing and
you're [ __ ] 40 you probably suck you
why because if you were any good you
would have picked it up sooner so if
you're you know deciding to play the
music and [ __ ] you fifty and then
somebody's saying hey dude you suck
don't do that they're not a hater you're
a [ __ ] idiot and you suck at what
you're doing okay so if you're a hater
fine no I'm not saying that they're all
right there are people out there that it
was like a [ __ ] that they hear um you
know if caddy Katy Perry I always say
caddy cuz it's spelled that way if Katy
Perry was going to act in a movie
immediately they just like a [ __ ] that
she sucks but that's because she doesn't
do what she do but now there is a chance
she could do that and look she's
obviously got some emotional depth she
can sing with the best of him she
murders some songs and you can feel it
in your soul maybe she's a good actress
but my point is there are haters but my
larger point is if you're 40 and you
pick up a guitar you suck
um so don't you don't get to hide behind
that hater notion you don't get to do
that okay I think Bruce Willis tried to
start a band once yeah I mean I'm not
that he gives a [ __ ] about haters but I
think you know you have friends that do
that [ __ ] oh dude you're being a hater
no you're just being a [ __ ] you just
have access to too much [ __ ] and ye goes
too big he goes too big um people are we
live in a world now where people are
where that's how it is though right
where people just want to call people
out for other [ __ ] because that's well
that's the Internet that's what happens
right I was in this conversation with
this girl the other day and she was
explaining to me that like guys just
want to [ __ ] and that's not true
you know I mean I know I said that on
incorrigible as a joke and all that [ __ ]
but guys don't just want to [ __ ] I'm
tired of guys getting the rap of just
wanting to [ __ ] right because I have a
lot of friends out there that are dudes
and these girls and [ __ ] will be like
did you
trying to [ __ ] me but that's not fair
guys don't just want to [ __ ] guys want
to also sit with somebody that they can
[ __ ] have a conversation with and be
cool about it and there's a lot between
like because a girl will say oh you know
uh I don't just want to [ __ ] but like we
can be friends which is fine but there's
a lot in between that right like there's
a lot in between that like oh oh you
don't want to be friends excuse me you
just want to [ __ ] no no it's not black
and white and you're going way too far
overboard that's like saying oh um you
know that's it's literally like saying
oh you don't like red well then you must
like purple at there's so many colors
you can like green hey what about green
hey what about green right so you can be
friends and also [ __ ] you can be my
girlfriend right just [ __ ] is a not
fair to say because no guy read no guy
really just wants to [ __ ] right I mean I
suppose you know you know who just wants
to [ __ ] actually married guys that cheat
married guys just want to [ __ ] but
you're not gonna [ __ ] hang out with
that guy anyway
unless yeah you know a secret
you know philandering uh really really
you know dark-hearted you know see
unless her secret philandering
dark-hearted [ __ ] hey your secret
philandering dark-hearted [ __ ] no well
then you can hang out with a guy and not
worry about just [ __ ] right how about
when a guy's like you want to go to
dinner um I don't well like that okay
some guys can come off like real real
sincere and [ __ ] and some girls will
just be like hey I was wondering if you
wanted to meet up for coffee and then in
girl baked
yeah you secret philandering
dark-hearted [ __ ] um yeah but guys
don't just want to [ __ ] I just feel like
I need to say that for guys a guy wants
a person that they can hang out with
period guy or girl and if your girl and
they're attracted to you also they want
to have sex yeah
but they don't just want to [ __ ] it's
not something I mean I don't know maybe
there's guys that there's like nah bro
I'm gonna bang the whole summertime and
that's it
revolving door do you know I'm gonna
[ __ ] put a revolving door in my in my
house on my [ __ ] apartment and just
[ __ ] basically have the ladies just
rollin pluck them and then late have
them leave um I don't know haters uh you
know what's getting hater
you know what's getting a bunch of hate
is there's this snow white movie coming
out and it's so funny it's like one of
those things that like they they like
the company it's like called like Lux or
some [ __ ] I can't remember but there's
this uh snow white a movie coming out
and it's like what if Snow White was
ugly and then Snow White is like
literally just like a little she's like
plump and like it's not like she's like
grotesque ugly um and and people are
like [ __ ] lighting it up like how
could you say just because she's plump
she's ugly because most people are plump
so like they're so offended by it
but it kills me that somebody is that
offended by it to be honest that that's
what
like if I was plump like I don't and and
then that came out I wouldn't really
give a [ __ ] I guess people are just so
insecure that like if somebody comes out
and makes fun of something that they
[ __ ] feel like they're upset about
whether they identify with and they they
they have nothing to do except [ __ ]
tweet about it and then it becomes a
viral thing but uh look that company can
do
look okay here's the thing if ugly is a
word then it exists okay it's in the
[ __ ] dictionary if ugly is a word
then it exists now you can't say oh but
everybody's beautiful in their own way
oh oh really no [ __ ] dude no [ __ ]
oh you mean there aren't people who are
[ __ ] Gargamel
oh you mean [ __ ] Gargamel doesn't
exist
oh you mean Loki isn't real
no [ __ ] everyone's beautiful in their
own way we're all colors and shades of
[ __ ] of a human oh dude oh really
everybody's beautiful in their own way
and I can't go look for Skeletor it's so
stupid dude but if ugly exists then you
can be [ __ ] ass ugly dude and that's
okay and that's fine that's okay hey
there's [ __ ] I don't know if you can
say midgets or not but there are short
people right you say short people now or
whatever little people they exist okay
if you're saying someone isn't ugly then
I don't know and that's it then you're
saying little people don't exist because
they do tall people don't exist that's a
word that exists fat people are fat some
people are fat as [ __ ] and you can say
that because the word exists if the word
didn't exist yeah look you know what's
[ __ ] up if I say someone's flaw lippo
because that word doesn't exist then I'm
being [ __ ] them you know then I just
started a [ __ ] prejudicial slur or
whatever dude some people I know are
[ __ ] ugly as [ __ ] and you know what
that's okay yeah they're beautiful in
their own way because they're not
Skeletor because they're not Loki
because they're not [ __ ] doomsday the
guy who broke [ __ ] Superman's back or
no that was Bane or no that was Bane who
killed Batman doomsday killed Superman
hey it's a dork
actually it wasn't baying that killed
Superman Chris alia it was less do we
forget it was actually uh it was
actually doomsday so just makes me laugh
how sometimes people just call out comic
books and think that they know what
they're saying when in actuality it's
actually not what happened so it just
makes me laugh um yeah so anyway I got
some [ __ ] friends are ugly as [ __ ]
that's what I'm trying to say by the way
I look like a bird okay so who cares if
they came out with a [ __ ] movie that
was like hey what if [ __ ] Prince
Charming was bird like and then [ __ ]
cartoon look like me you think I would
[ __ ] go on the internet and be like
hey [ __ ] Pixar no I think [ __ ] that
[ __ ] is hilarious I look like a bird
and people are gonna say I look like
that now and now people are gonna make
fun of me and I'm gonna use it too then
laughs and then also turn it into
success on my own life right maybe just
fat piece of [ __ ]
hey dude hey if you're upset about what
the [ __ ] that company did with the fat
snow white person hey maybe don't be fat
piece of [ __ ] uh uh probably getting in
trouble for all that but not really I
don't really matter that much so
probably not oh and then the Bill Maher
thing which was like how he said the
n-word um
I mean dude here's what I think about
that whole thing if you actually think
if you've never heard if you if you
watch the episode and I didn't see the
whole episode I saw the clip but if you
think that what Bill Maher did makes him
a racist then you're [ __ ] you don't
you don't have a grasp on what a [ __ ]
racist says I think he here's the bottom
line
he's a he's a comedian he has a show
that's a comedy and he made a joke
whether or not he went too far okay
that's kind of I guess that could be the
point but like he you can't make the
joke he made without saying that word
and whether or not you think it was
right or wrong that he did it to think
that he's racist is absolutely is just
is off the mark dude that's just off the
[ __ ] mark man that's like
disrespecting real racists and like it's
just so I mean people are calling to
remove and fire his show that's just way
overboard man like it's way overboard he
made a joke he was trying to make people
laugh a comedian doing his job what we
employ him to do if you didn't like the
joke if you thought it was offensive
then [ __ ] then [ __ ] fine but to be
that outraged and then call him a racist
is just off the mark man it's off the
[ __ ] mark completely it's off the
mark completely dude now it's hard to
say I'm a white guy so I get it you know
I you know you say oh but you're a
[ __ ] white guy you have privilege and
you don't know what that were okay fine
he was still trying to make a joke and
he was making a joke and you know what
people laughed at it in that room so
they're just as guilty as he is so fire
them for being an audience member the
guy he was across from laughed firing it
why don't you know who the [ __ ] he was
interviewing probably some politician
fire him
um yeah it's just I'm tired of this
[ __ ] outrage from I mean look Kathy
Griffin what she did with the with the
head the Trump thing it's like III
thought that was too much I thought what
she did was not funny tonally it was off
but all she had to be what oh you know
you I don't know if she was trying to
make a joke or not maybe she was I
didn't I I don't know but if she was
then she failed and fine I failed
millions of time
making jokes millions a lot I don't know
if I've said a million things but you
know if you're if you're there and and
you're in the room and you're taking the
picture and the you know you take the
picture and and then you think oh [ __ ]
well this is crazy let's do this and
fine
and I don't know her apology was kind of
now she's saying
Trumbo leader I mean you held a headless
Trump with blood on it you know it's
like you Bullock to I don't know I just
get sensitive about the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
the whole cultures like that now though
like I guess I don't mean to get too
head you know like too deep because I'm
just not that smart but like look look
at yourself you know what I mean like I
feel like people who get mad at at Bill
Maher and call him racist for that I
feel like they're doing that because
they feel guilty about being white and
being and how and how this country has
treated you know black people and that's
it's bad how this country is treated
black people but also that's not going
to firing Bill Maher is not the answer
is basically what I'm saying I mean I
can't believe I'm getting this goddamn
series about this [ __ ] podcast but
yeah it makes me [ __ ] angry as a
human
let's talk about something lighter
actually because anyway ya know what I'm
saying is look if you're [ __ ] that
makes you that up just look inside of
yourself like a Celine Dion song or some
[ __ ] because you know I read this
article recently that was about and it
it's step it's called Studios are
blaming Rotten Tomatoes for popcorn
movies bombing independent co uk this is
where the article was from
um that's really [ __ ] funny because
there are also God dude how ripped is
the rock I'm looking at the rock right
now in this [ __ ] picture I guess is a
picture of Baywatch studios are blaming
Rotten Tomatoes for popcorn movies
bombing that's a [ __ ] that's a
[ __ ] critic the Ron tomato's pools
the critics [ __ ] thoughts on movies
and then just gives it a percentage how
do you blame critics critics just don't
make [ __ ] hole movies I mean I don't see
these movies but popcorn movies bombing
so they're saying since it takes the
[ __ ] I guess there isn't much to say
about I [ __ ] just did you make shitty
movies then people are going to review
them shittily and then that's it it's
not the people to reveal who reviews
fault that your movie did shitty you
made shitty movie or you had bad
marketing I didn't see Baywatch I heard
people say it was funny but uh uh
starting off the referring I didn't read
article obviously like it like a really
informed person I just saw the headline
and now I'm talking about it and didn't
read the article so please don't take
what I'm saying seriously but by the way
white a [ __ ] blah but I can't print
this [ __ ] out why doesn't why don't
printers ever work you know what doesn't
work
two things [ __ ] never work two
[ __ ] things never work printers and
dishwashers dude I have you aimed I have
clean plates has anybody had a [ __ ]
clean plate in their house as soon as
you use it you put in a [ __ ]
dishwasher and you get my you get a fork
back and it's got like some [ __ ]
stood on it that you've never you know
I didn't trust and it's [ __ ] you got
to wash it twice or you got to wash it
before how about this yeah how about the
fact that remember when your mom when
you were younger she'd be like you got
to rinse it off and wash it before you
put it in the dishwasher if I gotta
watch the [ __ ] plate before I put in
the dishwasher why don't I just watch
the [ __ ] plate
what'd I just watch the [ __ ] plate we
don't need a [ __ ] dishwasher [ __ ]
these dishwasher companies and then [ __ ]
also how they're like oh but this
dishwasher works even better than the
last one you saw me the [ __ ] last one
you sold me the last one ah but this one
really works figure it out then sell it
every [ __ ] wireless printer every
wireless printer oh [ __ ] this is this is
you're doing it how it was the thing
where's the [ __ ] thing it didn't come
up on the reset it reset that you know
just turn your phone off and on and then
turn it back on oh no it still doesn't
work reset the printer oh go through the
configurations and I'm [ __ ] at the
printer now I don't need the Bluetooth
thing if I got to read to the
configuration every [ __ ] time I could
just plug it the goddamn [ __ ] in
companies need to figure out the [ __ ]
look dude when I go on stage I [ __ ]
do I do my job okay I make people laugh
it's very rare that people don't laugh
if you make a dishwasher if you're a
[ __ ] dishwasher company make your
dishwasher work there's some [ __ ]
first of all problems I don't give a
[ __ ] don't sell this [ __ ] if it doesn't
work III don't like it I know like it I
always feel like it's kind of like uh
you're stealing uh they're stealing
money you know like they're trying to
cut cost and make it all [ __ ] and
[ __ ] not do is well as they like did
you see that the founder movie with
about McDonald's and with Michael Keaton
my cookie was really good that movie I
can't um I cannot believe that
McDonald's got behind it it's AB it's a
movie about McDonald's about the the it
expanded how it turned how it was a
family-owned thing and then how this
Michael Keaton guy whoever he played was
a real guy came along and started like
franchising it and how he [ __ ] bought
this family out and ruined their
families like company and McDonald's
obviously had a lot to do with the movie
because they used the name you can't use
the name if McDonald's doesn't say it's
ok so they saw this movie about this guy
being a ruthless psychopath and we're
like McDonald's was like yeah cool we
liked that movie go ahead that's so that
made me a fan of McDonald's like I don't
eat that [ __ ] because cancer because
when you put a burger in your mouth
that's like saying hey give me cancer
but McDonald's was like yo we did what
we did so [ __ ] it and they didn't really
romanticize it they just were like the
guy was a piece of [ __ ] and they made it
they made him be a piece of [ __ ] and it
it shocked me that McDonald's [ __ ]
you know the movies okay was it was it
wasn't bad it was just like weird it was
like weird that McDonald's was was
basically saying this guy was a piece of
[ __ ] and then our company became huge
and we watch the movie and now we know
we'll [ __ ] the secret's out but
nobody gives a [ __ ] they'll still cram
[ __ ] burgers in their faces they
still want cancer um yeah I don't know
[ __ ] but up up I you know what I mean
that's the truth
hey dude but up by if I ever [ __ ]
heard it hey guys time to talk about
blue apron it's the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the country so why wouldn't you get
on board with that why would you not get
on board with the number one you won't
be number two you wanna be number eight
or you wanna be number one then get with
blue apron the reference mission is to
is to make incredible home cook
accessible home cooking accessible to
everyone and you know what they did it
that was their mission and they mission
accomplished
okay it's got an impact on the community
man you know you want to be if you want
to be part of the community of this blue
apron has established partnerships with
over 150 local farms fisheries and
ranchers across the United States
now that means the seafood is sourced
sustainably under standards developed in
partnership with the Monterey Bay
Aquarium Seafood Watch they're doing
this the right way and they're making it
communal and they're helping our lives
blue apron can be delivered to 99% of
the continental US so you live there
probably if you're listening so uh it's
affordable
it's got variety it's it's easy each
meal comes with a step-by-step
easy-to-follow recipe card and
pre-portion ingredients that can be
prepared in 40 minutes or less so you
know get it and make it easier on you
and your family your family cook cooks
together your family become stronger you
go to blue apron dot-com / Congrats
if you check out this meat week's menu
and get you can get your first three
meals free with free
shipping go to blue apron dot-com /
Congrats blue apron is a better way to
cook so go to blue apron comm / Congrats
square cash you know what square cash is
you listen to this podcast babies then
you know what square cash is do you use
it yet if you do you're a true baby if
you don't then what are you doing
because square cows is the best way to
pay people for stuff and that's it
that's the end that's the end of story
restaurants you can do coffee with
friends if you know you order food on
another app and the app gets delivered
and you're doing it for your friends
then you'd be like yo yours was a 50
send me that and use square cash to do
that right
maybe you got a you know your mom's sad
you want to send her 35 bucks do that
with square cash where she live Wyoming
and you live here then send it to her
you square cash your mom bring it goes
immediate no extra gimmicks no [ __ ]
just payments in your bank done and your
mom's happier
she's a materialistic you know person so
give her 35 bucks and do with square
cash download the free square cash app
for iOS or Android now do it anyway for
your consideration [ __ ] vote this
podcast for an Emmy I love I love the
for your consideration [ __ ] it's so
funny man they'll have like for your
consideration and they'll do the worst
shows like because like some actor they
want to just impress him
the for your consideration some are
great like I'll be like mr. robot and
[ __ ] you know for your consideration
house of cards and you're like no [ __ ]
you don't even need this billboard you
don't even need to think that this ad in
variety it's already going to get
nominated but my favorite is when it's
like for your consideration
fart McGillicutty and poopy head [ __ ]
balls on [ __ ] poop the broadcast
central
datian pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] and you're
like like you're not going to get
nominated who you trying to impress the
[ __ ] guy who's in the wheelchair in
your in your in your show dude you know
what bothers me too they try to make
every show politically correct like
there's always a guy in a wheelchair or
a gay guy in every show and that's
offensive to guys in wheelchairs and gay
guys but nobody thinks that because
everyone thinks we're doing it right
because hey they finally got their shot
there's so many gay guys on TV I can't
even believe it every characters gay
every shows got a gay guy now and they
think that that's like these network
executives will be like well maybe one
of them should [ __ ] guys and then that
makes their show like culturally like
relevant they start all bad it's like
that's like literally being like hey
well maybe we'll make one of the guys a
black belt in karate
like that's not you know have it start
from the [ __ ] inside out not the
outside in dude even when they do it
with like basic [ __ ] like Sex in the
City how one person had blond hair one
person was a brunette one person was a
redhead how many [ __ ] redheads do you
know and one of the [ __ ] they made
her one of the characters a redhead like
each woman was a [ __ ] one of your
friends look this one liked to sleep
around and that's her personality and
this other one
she was the quiet one that didn't do
much like people are like people aren't
all all of that you know like people
like like there aren't like hey if you
[ __ ] a lot of guys that's who you are
you [ __ ] a lot of guys no no y'all so
not that you also sometimes don't do
because you're real person
pairen oh man that's what good shows
like [ __ ] real good shows like
[ __ ] Sopranos and the wire I guess I
mean though that was less of a
character-driven piece um but like
Breaking Bad and [ __ ] like you're just
like and Mad Men you're just like the
bad guys are the good guys and the good
guys are the bad guys I like seeing that
[ __ ] and people like seeing that [ __ ]
and that's what [ __ ] makes you want
to go back to watch the show I mean look
there's that and then there's also Big
Bang Theory which is nothing like that
and that's fine and that's comforting
and it's funny and people love that show
and it's obviously very successful and
it's killing it good for them that holds
its place in in in what we need to in
what in in entertainment
huh I don't know dude um by the way I
was at the Comedy Store the other night
and I went onstage and you know I feel
like I had a good show I'm working this
new material that I was that I was not
on man on fire which comes out June 27th
on Netflix only um and so I had a good
set and I brought up Joey Diaz on stage
a lot of you guys know Joey Diaz uh and
goddamn that guy is [ __ ] funny man I
mean he is just so [ __ ] funny man
and he just leveled the place then I
watched um Brody Stephens who also is
[ __ ] so funny that the two of them
together back-to-back was just it was so
funny and then I saw this guy Steve
Simone which who is so also so [ __ ]
funny at the Comedy Store man the Comedy
Store
I was just sitting there watching these
guys and you know after I went on and
like I literally feel so lucky to be
among those guys and to be performing on
that stage and to be in this moment in
time too because of how big and good
comedy has gotten to be there on a on a
[ __ ] what was it when when what it
was today was some oh so it was a Sunday
night on a Sunday well way off Oh
Wednesday no the the exact opposite of
Wednesday Sunday okay the farthest away
from okay so the furthest away from
Wednesday to be doing that and to be it
just it felt awesome man I was sitting
back and I don't really watch comedy
that much because you're there and
you've seen it a lot and I've been
traveling and you do your own thing to
get hooked in your own [ __ ] but I sat
and I watched
Joey and Steve Simone and Brody and man
it would it just it gave me a feeling
that that felt so good it felt
full you know like almost how it feels
like when I'm with my family having
dinner I get like a war an actual warm
feeling in my heart like and it feels
good because I don't normally feel that
feeling that much because you get so
consumed with the daily life of it all
and you're [ __ ] navigating through
your own [ __ ] that when you actually
realize oh [ __ ] I feel good right now
and you sit and you try to not take
advantage of it and you re you try to
take advantage of it and you try to sit
and just realize you're feeling away and
not take it for granted is what I'm
trying to say is just is just it makes
me feel so lucky and fortunate and happy
and it's awesome to be there at the
Comedy Store this place is on fire dude
these comedians that the lineups every
night are insane and and every show is
sold out always I love when my friend
friends text me oh man I'm here I didn't
realize it was gonna be sold out oh you
didn't realize it was going to be sold
out with [ __ ] Joe Rogan David Spade
[ __ ] Joey Diaz uh uh Anthony Jeselnik
[ __ ] Sebastian you oh you didn't
realize it was gonna be sold out when
any one of those guys could sell out
places four times as big like it's just
awesome Judd Apatow all the time I mean
all these guys can [ __ ] sell [ __ ] out
um Ali Wong
iliza shlesinger I mean these guys
they're all everyone here is selling out
all across the country
and people show up and try to get
tickets like there and and you drive by
sunset and the lines down the block it's
it's the best it's the best I was
talking to Rogan the other day and he
was like dude I he's that comedies never
been this hot since he's been a [ __ ]
doing comedy um and that's just crazy me
has definitely never been as hot since
I've been doing comedy but I've been
doing it since I've been doing since
I've been doing stand-up but I've been
doing it since
not that long of as Rogen and that's
what he said so that's [ __ ] awesome
I'm just so happy about it you gotta
check out the Comedy Store the other
clubs are good too man but the the
Comedy Store has some kind of pulse to
it right now
and that's that's it it feels like
important well this guy made this I'm
looking at this now I'm looking at the
congratulations pod twitter at hashtag
definition of a CUDA have you seen this
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god that's [ __ ] hilarious dude
LDN will at LDN will holy [ __ ] that's
hilarious
I'm gonna retweet that right now he
[ __ ] game the system hard ah man I
mean it was perfect I was like Drake
with lil yachty Conda type hair um oh my
god that's hilarious I'm put it again
[Music]
that's cool there I like it I love when
people make [ __ ] dude like that it's
such an ego boost and I'm such a piece
of [ __ ] and it makes me laugh ah man I
love how people hit me up hey what's the
song on on congratulations hey I had it
made
how can I get it I had it made I paid
for it I had it made because it's saying
congratulations over and over again it's
by mr. green who's a hip hop producer
and he's great he did a lot of shanks
myths music I don't know if you guys
know Chang Smith but you should look him
up this is a good one
Penza at Penn's I'm in Franklin change
it don't be so cute bro you change it
hey dude you grown male change it pens
them in Franklin after your recent
acting work being serious not comedic do
you think you want to do more serious
roles in the future that's honestly what
I want to do that's all I want to do I'd
like to find the [ __ ] humor in the
roles a little of them but like real
life humor you know I want to do like I
said like I want to play a Japanese man
with no makeup and do it real for real
that would nothing but be funnier but I
do I want to do like my comedy outlet
dude I don't there's so many corny
comedies that come out nowadays I just
I'd rather just do my style of stand-up
and then do like actual real roles that
are like real kind of realer characters
I don't want to play a guy who was like
whoopsie
you know I want to play a [ __ ] actual
person that charges me more yeah that
was by Penza min Franklin so thanks
change it oh I talked about
this somewhere the other day and so this
guy comes into this coffee bean and I'm
in the coffee bean it's on the he's on
the patio and he's got like I don't
understand what this isn't I don't know
if this happens everywhere else in
America but in LA if you sit at a coffee
shop long enough there will be someone
that shows up with an old am/fm radio
that plays it for everybody and it'll be
like the radio and he's just playing the
radio and this happened the other day
this guy [ __ ] had the radio showed up
put the radio on the table sat down and
was listening to the radio now he was an
older guy because who the [ __ ] has an
am/fm radio cept unless you're 70 but
this guy was playing it for all of us I
don't remember what song it was but not
all of us wanted to hear that song get
headphones not all of us wanted to hear
that song absolutely get headphones now
okay you might be like well maybe he
can't afford headphones fine keep the
goddamn radio then somewhere else or off
so the guy's sitting down having the
[ __ ] radio on playing by the way the
commercials are playing to getting real
angry I don't want to have to be a
sucker for this advertisement this guy's
just [ __ ] so I get up I walk over to
the guy and I [ __ ] look at the am/fm
radio I find the stop button and I hit
stop and then I walk over to my I expect
this guy's gonna be like you
[ __ ]
doesn't say [ __ ] I walk over to my table
sit back down and that's the end of the
story
I thought it was going to be a fantastic
crazy story that this guy was going to
want to fight me or something but like I
and here's the deal I didn't want to get
into a confrontation I didn't want to
get into a fight obviously I never want
to get into a fight but if you're going
to bring an am/fm radio to a cafe or a
coffee shop or anywhere in public
you're breaking the [ __ ] rules period
I know it's not against the law well
Addison kinda is is noise pollution but
you're breaking the rules okay so I walk
up and I fix that you broke the rules so
Johnny mnemonic comes by and [ __ ]
pauses your goddamn radio I saved the
world right there I saved the world and
I don't mean that tongue-in-cheek I'm
saving the world when I do that and you
are too
okay you got to [ __ ] help these
[ __ ] out you're helping them
you're helping them if you turn off this
radio you're helping everybody around
and you're also helping them know how to
be the guy got up took his am/fm radio
walked all the way down to the other
side of the patio where I wasn't on
started playing the [ __ ] music again
okay there were three people next to him
having like some sort of an actual
discussion maybe it was a business
meeting or something this guy plays it
just as loud as it did okay the woman in
the table gets up walks over and says
excuse me sir can you turn that lower
please and he does and then she walks
back down now she saved the world dude
and I mean that lunatic lunatic disgust
of the gym that do that they bring a
little [ __ ] am/fm thing hey man I
don't want to listen to journey while
I'm doing skull Crusher's I want to
listen to what is in my ears that's why
I brought the [ __ ] and put them in
Mayer's or I want to listen to nothing
how about that or I want to listen to
music at the gym dude it's just when
someone takes it upon themselves to play
the [ __ ] music for people I want to
do roundhouse kicks repeatedly to their
face it's the same as [ __ ] picking
but guitar and playing it at a party
it's actually that's way worse but it's
still bad
don't let these [ __ ] get away
with that [ __ ] you know why dude you
know why you don't let these
[ __ ] get away with this [ __ ]
I'm gonna tell you why okay Internet god
damn [ __ ] cool hey Internet way
to ruin the joke hey Internet play it
hey Internet play it dude don't have the
Internet if it doesn't work don't have
the Internet if it doesn't work cool not
working
yay the Internet's not working
yay that's know that's what I want to do
when I'm [ __ ] pissed off I want to go
yeah yeah um what is this here okay uh
here we go uh this is a there's a
there's a video it just bugs the [ __ ]
out of me there's a video at the Laugh
Factory YouTube that of me [ __ ] with
this guy in the crowd and his name is
Dylan and it's got like three million
hits or something and it's Dylan O'Brien
the movie star I guess you'd say he's
kind of a movie star actually this was
way before he was a on Teen Wolf or
anything right and he looks 12 and it's
obvious it was way before anything and
it drives me nuts that people comment
hey did you know you were making fun of
the guy from [ __ ] what's the movie
he's in with the The Maze Runner oh no I
didn't know that because I'm not a time
traveler I didn't know that because I'm
not in Sky Captain and the World of
Tomorrow
that's why but only dude you know the
reason why I didn't know that only
because I'm not the sky captain and I'm
not in the world of tomorrow that's all
that's it the only reason why I don't
know that that's the guy from Maze
Runner is because I'm not Scott Bakula
in quantum leap um yeah so and then
people will be like dude and every
comment is did you know this was dylan
o'brien well yeah because everybody
commented it be ridge I know freak punch
and you can comment whatever you want
but B ridge B Ridge it's free conch you
can comment every more whatever you want
all day long but B Ridge that's the
thing dude yeah you can play an am/fm
radio in a cafe for everybody but B
person B person in society right that's
it that's a situation where you can't be
rich okay cuz you bothering everyone
else at the [ __ ] coffee bean and
that's the [ __ ] time where if you do
that I love how is big cube ugly Crudup
definition of Arad I love how to bark
would do that [ __ ] a definition to prod
that's so funny um so anyway yeah let's
look at more gaming the systems and then
I'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of here
uh congratulations pod chillin thanks
for listening to these you guys were
just chillin at your workplace you know
hey internet doesn't work yeah I mean it
doesn't want I can't look at the
congratulations potash tag
II how about when it was the
International donut day or whatever the
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that was members
donate day and everyone was like can't
wait the donuts eat donuts when you want
eat donuts you can't [ __ ] have a day
dude you're not gonna tell me what you
doughnuts you're not gonna [ __ ] tell
me you're not gonna get me to want eat
donuts cuz it's a specific day the [ __ ]
am i an ant what am i a [ __ ] that's
kuta [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] definition of
the kuda you see something you want
something because you're a [ __ ]
barracuda do your own [ __ ] if you waited
donut an international or national donut
day whatever the [ __ ] it was you khuda
eat khuda dude eat a donut [ __ ] that
need a donut the day before it in the
day after year donut in the national
donut day eat code don't do that
Valentine's Day eat my [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I hate it too because if you were
the girl you got to celebrate it even if
the girls like no I know it's that it's
like a hollow mark holiday they made it
you know they created it just to make
money
don't say that when deep down you want
flowers don't say that when deep down
you 140 chocolates don't say that when
deep down you want sushi and you want me
to pay two hundred and ten dollars for a
meal don't say right oh I don't know but
then and then you feel okay so we won't
do anything so then you feel bad though
when your friends do something when your
friends gottschalk when your friends got
flour and your friends got tors-10 sushi
you don't automation on national donut
day can't talk to you dude can't trust
you can't trust you
thanks LD n WI ll um will.i.am dude
the name will.i.am you know [ __ ]
will.i.am
will you not William okay will.i.am
now hey nah dude real quick
hey dude will.i.am real quick yo hey
real quick nah
hey will.i.am real quick you William you
put a dot in the middle of your [ __ ]
name oh cool you're a robot you're not a
robot take the dot out
hey india dot re india dot re dude i'm
gonna be cut wrists christow dot fir hey
dude you got him you put a [ __ ]
period in your name holy [ __ ]
you gotta be an enraged in an enraging
[ __ ] you have to be an unbelievable I
mean well I mean you know Christo dot
fir imagine imagine that imagine meeting
somebody with a [ __ ] period in their
name
I do roundhouse kicks to the face all
day long in my mind a drill house kicks
them up it to the face all day long in
the mud Wow
alright dude well we're about to wrap it
up um Apple introduced a new computer
that's ten thousand dollars so that's
cool so go buy that if you're you know
go buy that everybody seems like
everyone will probably be able to afford
that and they came up with Apple home
too which is cool man cool way to go way
to go to do that even though there's
Alexa and [ __ ] all the other things
every company is the same company cool
Oh Instagram and snapchat Oh Instagram
is going to do the filters uncle ello
Instagram is going to do the filters and
they're going to do all the filters that
the [ __ ] that snapchat does and then
when I post someone else's photo they're
gonna take it down and flag it hey pick
one Hey
Oh you're gonna rip snapchat from the
[ __ ] bones and then when I post a
picture that's from stock photo you gun
flag it hey Instagram pic hey I have a
really simple thing for you pic right
hey don't do that
we'll do it that's what you're saying
hey you can't do that we'll do it
Instagram hey you can't do that we'll do
it
um I mean you know that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] right hey don't post a
picture someone else posted by the way
we're snapchat now Oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] definition of a CUDA all
right uh well we game the system we
talked it all out and we had a good time
and I just want everybody to know I'm
gay no I'm kidding but what if I did
come out like that at the end of my
podcast after all that dumb [ __ ] I said
and then by the way guys I'm gay I'm a
homosexual and I've been [ __ ] guys
for so long and I'm coming out of the
closet now and it feels terrific I'm out
now all right so that's it man we did it
in the 19th episode listen to me guys
listen to me I'm not going to keep doing
this podcast if you don't tweet about it
if you don't get your friends to listen
if you don't get them to [ __ ] rate
and review it if you don't do it not
gonna do it if you don't do it I'm not
going to do it how am I going to [ __ ]
make this cult how am I going to [ __ ]
keep you babies for real if you're not
going to be my babies and if you're not
going to [ __ ] be in my cult and do
the cult duties dude get on the [ __ ]
ball
tell people about it if you don't gun
stop if you don't think I'm gonna stop
really let's take a moment in history do
it I used to do ten minute podcast stop
ding get big enough okay I'll stop again
bro um yeah so you know I got upcoming
show dates coming out go to my website
crystally accom got crazy [ __ ] going to
Baltimore what I'm gonna go look at then
take the [ __ ] wired tour
I'm gonna look for Trayvon Barksdale or
whatever the guys name was and uh and um
and then also West Palm Beach dude you
want to chill you want to come out in
white linen come see me in West Palm
Beach because they definitely wear white
linen there they got [ __ ] wear the
same color shorts as they do shirts
everybody hated everybody take a fashion
tip from P Diddy in West Palm Beach yeah
but there's 70 also so if you're young
come out please because you know don't
want them all to be 70 because that's a
retirement community no doubt it also
feels like it's in The Truman Show
because it is very weird going to be in
let me look at some of these dates
actually here I'm gonna roll off I'm
gonna rattle off a few and then you guys
are go get tickets Montreal I'm going to
be in ront Montreal I'm going to be in
Atlantic City Baltimore Atlantic City
Huntington New York two shows West Palm
Beach Austin Texas Albuquerque New
Mexico
why don't know Montreal um Nashville
Tennessee Salt Lake Utah Phoenix Arizona
Tempe Arizona Spokane Washington why
Charlotte North Carolina
very hard to sell tickets there Irvine
California always sells out 75 months
beforehand so get your phone I don't
know what it is about that man um so get
your tickets also doing more so
that's what's up and also um what else
do I want to say before I go man on fire
June 27th baby my new special comes out
on Netflix so put that in your queue man
on fire June 27th tweet me at hashtag
congratulations pod rate and review the
show really iTunes Google Play stitcher
tweet about it Instagram story about it
snapchat it get that [ __ ] word out
there for your true baby all right I
really appreciate that
and don't forget to check out this
week's menu sign up and get first three
meals for free with free shipping at
blue apron calm slash Congrats have fun
my babies
[Music]
thank you